one of the things that happened on
Monday and and if this took a day or two
to really register Jack Del Rio who
seems to be intent on spending this year
in the media was on NFL Network and he
said regarding this looming effort by
Russell Wilson to get a new contract and
if he doesn't he may go year to year
under the franchise tag Del Rio said
this when he was asked about the
possibility of Russell Wilson getting a
new contract in Seattle don't be
surprised if before it's all said and
done when we line up for the season next
year if Russell Wilson isn't quarterback
in somewhere else and the Seahawks
Seahawks haven't gone and gotten a
quarterback they think for the future
you know it's funny how he said CX I
wonder how many years he went Colin and
the Seahawks I wonder if that's what
they call it with coaches or other teams
call him the Seahawks but regardless the
idea that Russell Wilson could be traded
now the 17 million dollar salary this
year I don't know what the Seahawks
would do a quarterback your reaction
when you heard Jack Del Rio throw that
out there for consumption that maybe
this guy gets traded well my first
reaction was I cannot believe Jack Del
Rio is inserting himself into this story
and getting into the news cycle then
once I kind of woke up and realized it
wasn't a fever dream I started to
realize that I kind of agree with him
and I think a couple weeks ago I was on
this very show and I said everything's
gonna work out fine cuz Russell Wilson
won't hold out but the more I think
about it and the more time that goes by
it's crazy to say but the Seahawks might
be the first team that that does this
thing we've been talking about that
we've been alluding to with Jared Goff
or mister Biscay or these quarterbacks
that are gonna come up and one team's
gonna pass on giving them the big Matt
Ryan or Matthew Stafford deal could you
imagine if it was the Seahawks that was
that first team and I don't think it's
that crazy because they haven't publicly
said hey Russell Wilson is our guy we'll
get it done I remember Matt Ryan when he
was when his contract it was like a
foregone conclusion everyone just knew
that Matt Ryan was gonna get his
contract same with Aaron Rodgers they
basically laughed it off like oh yeah
we'll get that done
the Seahawks haven't given that sign
whatsoever so now I'm starting to think
this is a real possibility that Russell
will
will not be on the Seahawks in a year or
two well no but but Pete Carroll was
with us at the Scouting Combine and he
said yeah we want to get this deal done
we want him to be here we want to honor
the past and honor the future and we
want him to be our guy and they've
completely reconfigured the roster
around Russell Wilson and here's the
other thing too they have already paid
him close to market value the last time
he did his contract Aaron Rodgers was
the top of the stack at 22 million a
year when when Wilson did his last deal
and his average was twenty one point
nine million per year in new money so
they've already crossed that bridge of
paying Russell Wilson big money and that
was at a time when they still had some
rough-and-tumble guys on the team who
didn't like Russell Wilson most of those
guys are now gone Wilson is the center
of the Seahawks universe I can't imagine
that they haven't already when they made
all the changes last year to that team
that they haven't already crossed that
bridge that we're gonna have to pay this
guy big money sooner rather than later
so I can look I think when Del Rio says
don't be surprised if there's a trade
he's hearing something from somebody
that it's at least a possibility I just
can't imagine it happening now maybe
next year if Russell Wilson is just off
the charts with what he wants and he's
asking for so much
it's a pretext for wanting out of
Seattle but he's not trying to make it
look like it's not his idea but I just
think that the Seahawks have already
decided we're gonna do what we have to
do to keep this guy around and unless
he's making ridiculously unreasonable
demands they're gonna find a way to keep
him around
but the quarterback bubble is gonna
burst at some point dude wouldn't you
agree like at some point some team is
gonna be in this exact position maybe
not
the caliber that Russell Wilson is
because he is a top-five quarterback the
NFL but some team will be in a position
where they have a quarterback who feels
like a franchise quarterback who's gone
to the playoffs probably not want a
Super Bowl but won some big games and
they're gonna say you know what we're
gonna pass we're gonna pass we're gonna
we're gonna go back to the draft we're
gonna get a guy on his rookie deal we're
gonna mold another guy and build around
him
why would what like what the Seahawks
could be that first team you don't think
so
well I look at what Aaron Rodgers is
currently making at thirty three and a
half million per year the salary caps at
180
8.2 that's 17.8 percent of the total
salary cap that's not a ridiculous
percentage because that's the thing we
lose sight of the cap keeps going up
every year by 10 million 10 million 10
million it's gonna be over 200 million
we got new TV deals coming new CBA
coming gambling money is gonna drive up
the salary cap these numbers shouldn't
be as stunning if he wants 30 435
million a year they can find a way to
make that work but I agree with you at
some point somebody's going to say we're
just not going to do it but I think it's
more likely to happen when a team hasn't
already given a guy a close to market
value contract when you're at the end of
that rookie deal and you have to ask
yourself do we give this guy something
close to market value or do we let him
walk away
Washington's already done it with Kirk
Cousins after to franchise tags they
were at the point where it was going to
be 30 million plus for one year to keep
him they said no we're not gonna do it
we're not gonna sign with a long term
contract we're not doing it the only
difference is Kirk Cousins isn't a
franchise quarterback as evidenced by
his play last year but one of these guys
who really is a franchise quarterback at
some point they're gonna make the
strategic decision we'll just go to
round one of the draft we'll get one of
these young guys will run his college
system and we'll prop him up and turn
him into the next guy that we have to
eventually decide whether or not we're
gonna pay I want to go back to a point
you made Aaron Rodgers taking about 17%
of the Green Bay cap well it might not
seem like a lot it is a lot when you
talk about depth and what happens in
Green Bay every year it feels like every
single year they go through injuries and
they're they're on their second third
string offensive lineman and that really
kind of you know Aaron Rodgers covers up
for all those mistakes so when you're
talking about true team building the
depth is obviously a very important part
you saw the Rams this year they got to
the Superbowl the Rams
they had no depth they lose Cooper Cup
and their offense completely changes so
when you when you get it right up
against the cap and you use a lot of
your cap on a franchise quarterback it
might not be starters it might not be
that you can't go get other big names
but it probably means that you can't get
the depth that you need to survive an
NFL season and NFL playoffs yeah I mean
you either have a franchise quarterback
or you don't and I think teams need to
be more careful how they define
franchise quarterback
just because you have a guy who passes
the smell test and is around for three
or four years and you don't know who
else your quarterback would be that
doesn't mean he's the guy that you
should keep and we're gonna talk about
the Raiders situation coming up in a few
minutes they're kind of in the middle of
that right now with Derek Carr where
he's got kind of a franchise quarterback
caliber contract although it's been
leapfrog by seven or eight other guys
they have to ask themselves do we want
to keep making this financial commitment
to him when we could get somebody who
would be a lot cheaper relative to what
the draft now pays these guys as they
enter the league in the first round it
will be actually because what we're
talking about here is different than
that discussion because Russell Wilson
is a franchise quarterback so that's the
interesting part of this story is he is
not a Kirk Cousins a Derek Carr a
Matthew Stafford where you're basically
saying we got to talk ourselves into him
being a franchise quarterback you know
we can't let them walk because the fan
base is gonna get upset about it but we
really don't feel comfortable paying
them all this money you know what let's
just pay him so no one says hey you let
a guy walk out the door Russell Wilson's
not that guy Russell Wilson is a top
five quarterback he is fantastic he has
never been seriously injured he's got a
Super Bowl ring so that's where this is
a big story because if it's if it's
someone a little bit less of a cat you
know caliber quarterback than Russell
Wilson I think you say okay guess what
like you said Kirk Cousins walked away
you know the Redskins let him walk he's
not a franchise quarterback they didn't
talk themselves into it Russell Wilson
is a totally different situation and if
the Seahawks let him go I think it
changes the whole entire market because
everyone says hey there's a path to
winning here where you just don't ever
have to pay your quarterback that much
money do you think it was smart for the
Raiders to trade Kaleo Mack to the Bears
ah no no that that's the defensive
version of the argument you just made
the Raiders consciously chose not to pay
Khalil Mack the money that he would
command is one of the best defensive
players in all of football they gave and
the Bears are paying him twenty three
and a half million plus they gave up all
that draft capital to get him see that's
the other side of the coin somebody out
there I passed the test right I stayed
consistent right there
you did stay consistent yes but the
point is if it's a true shortlist
franchise quarterback you're gonna find
somebody out there like the Bears he'll
say wait a minute Russell
available yeah we'll give you two
first-round picks and we'll pay him
market value
I mean think of how much more the Bears
would have paid Khalil Mack if they
didn't have to give up draft picks to
get him they'd have paid him 30 million
a year so I agree with you Wilson
someone will play Russell Wilson but I'm
saying what will happen is if the
Seahawks let Russell Wilson walk out
that door and they still have success
that is now basically saying the NFL
here's a blueprint to continually being
in the hunt without having to pay a guy
a crazy amount of money there will
always be a market place for top five
quarterbacks and teams that say you know
what even if we do not trying to win a
Super Bowl we're just trying to fill
seats we're just trying to get the
fanbase to say hey we have our guy there
will always be a market for that but if
the Seahawks are able to maneuver
letting Russell Wilson leave and having
a blueprint thing staying you know
competitive and in the hunt of the
playoffs that's where I think everything
shifts all right let's say they would
trade him right now to the Giants for
picks number six and number 17 and with
pick number six they would take Dwayne
Haskins or drew Locke think of the
pressure that would put on that guy
walking through the door think of the
pressure it puts on John Schneider and
Pete Carroll I mean this is the ultimate
all-in move if you do this and I'm not
saying it won't happen I'm just I'm
trying to spin it forward you have a
shortlist franchise quarterback and we
know quarterback makes the NFL go around
it's the center of the universe for
every team you give that guy up because
you don't want to pay him and you
consciously trade trade yourself into a
spot where you've got a rookie that you
are putting all that pressure on him to
come in and be that Russell Wilson type
figure sooner rather than later if it
doesn't work everybody's getting fired
so that's that's a very good reason to
try to make it work with your franchise
quarterback because if you do this and
it blows up in your face you are out of
a job you're right on that but under
that same circumstances you just laid
out there what happens is Dwayne Haslam
goes to the playoffs next year not maybe
maybe not he's working here maybe his
sophomore year right what happens if he
goes to the playoffs
now everyone's looking at and say wait
hold on they got to the playoffs by true
by letting Russell
go and the Giants can't you know put out
a decent offensive line and they've
holes everywhere else everywhere else
because they're paying you know they're
running back and they're in their
quarterback a ton of money I'm just
saying like you know this is a copycat
league everyone right now is on this
whole trend of you got to have a rookie
a quarterback on a rookie deal you got
to have a quarterback on cheap money
that's what the Superbowl champions do
Tom Brady doesn't take up a ton of the
cap all these things if it works that
they let him go it's just going to
accelerate that entire line of thinking
that much more well it's just one hell
of an experiment because you you are
putting your job on the line if you are
the first one to say we're gonna trade a
franchise quarterback just like that is
similar to what the the Raiders did with
Kaleo Mack we're gonna trade a Hall of
Fame type player because we just don't
want to put that much money in one
player we want to spread it around to
others and we're gonna take our chances
with a rookie that's a hell of a risky
move and maybe someone will do it it's
good for us if someone does it because
this is a fascinating conversation it'd
be fun to watch without our jobs on the
line but whoever does it is going to
have their jobs squarely in the
crosshairs
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports